it was ten years ago that MTV's was
gonna be spin off the hills premiered
and it was hard so part reality and like
I mean totally drama all the time right
here's what I remember everyone hated
Spencer and Heidi they loved Lauren
Conrad and in honor of throwback
Thursday we tracked the entire cast down
to find out where are they now
and it realized at the time that it was
going to turn into this essentially soap
opera it was just a wild crazy time but
it was fun
beautiful people and they're delicious
drama millions of viewers couldn't get
enough Heidi Montag and Spencer Pratt
earned super villain street cred on the
hills the couple married in 2009 but
Spencer never lived down his rep for
amping up the crazy you're the biggest
poser in this town you know what you're
gonna burn the network told me oh this
show is getting pulled after season one
like they needed a bad guy so you know
everybody one for me being awful so
where are they now
Lawrence parlayed her kills Fame into a
reported twenty five million dollar
fashion and lifestyle empire and just
published her ninth book Kristin's a mom
of three and married to Chicago Bears
quarterback Jay Cutler we knew from our
very first interview with her that she
was destined to hit it big in the world
of fashion with her own shoe and jewelry
lines
BCBG my third fashion show of the day
and the rest of the